hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're looking at one of python's
sharpest corners the plus equals operator.
python is widely regarded as one of the
most intuitive programming languages
but no matter how intuitive
a programming language is it
will always have some features which
are a little bit subtle or confusing.
in python one of those things is the
plus equals operator let's take a look.
in this first example we're trying
to change one of the values of a
tuple but tuples are immutable so
this is a pretty obvious error.
in this case we cannot change the
value of tuple of zero because tuple
is immutable note however that it's the
tuple that's immutable, not its elements.
so in this case i have a tuple of pros and
cons which are both lists, you know pros of
subscribing and cons of subscribing, and even
though the tuple is immutable you can of course
get out the zeroth element, the
pros, and then add something to it.
that's fine.
you can see if i run it there's no errors.
okay so the tuple itself is immutable but the
zeroth element of the tuple is a list which
is not immutable, so will this syntax allow
me to append another element onto that list?
when i run the code i get the same error as
before telling me that i can't assign to a tuple.
let's see what happens if we catch that error
with a try except and then print out the list.
well we can see that it definitely hit the
error block but when we print out the list
it also appended the element, what's going on?
i think most people definitely expect it to either
give an error and not append anything or to append
something with no error, so why is it doing both?
well, sharp corner.
this is, according to the
documentation, a "feature" not a bug.
it has to do with the data
model and how plus equals
is supposed to work on different data types.
in order to get a slightly better understanding
let's take a look at what plus equals
actually translates to under the hood.
roughly this is what x plus equals y means.
it means create a temporary,
call this function iadd for in-place add
and then assign the result back to x.
when the left hand side of the plus equals
is an expression which is not just a simple
variable name then you can see that this
pattern expands out to something non-trivial.
filling in x sub 0 here shows us
that this actually calls the get
item method of x and similarly putting
it back here calls the set item method.
this is the reason that the list extend
succeeds but the tuple assignment fails.
this first line happily grabs
the zeroth element from the list
and then extends it which is what
the iadd method will do for a list,
but when it goes to reassign the result
back to x 0 that's where the error happens.
the exact same thing can happen
with something like x.val
but instead of calling the get item and set
item it will call the get attr and set attr.
so if you have an immutable object which
contains a mutable object like a list,
then you can run into the same kind of trouble.
okay so that's pretty wonky behavior.
why is that a feature and not a bug?
well actually even just basic
addition of integers depends on it.
if i set x to be 1 and then i say x plus equals
1, i expect x to be equal to 2 afterwards.
but in python integers are immutable,
i can't change a 1 into a 2.
i have to point the variable x from
a 1 to a different place to a 2.
you can see this by examining the unique id
that's printed out when i run the function.
initially x's id is whatever
the id is for the built-in one,
but afterwards it has to be the
built-in id for whatever two is.
that means that plus equals must have
changed the object that x points to.
this is very different from many
other languages where users have
direct access to built-in
primitive types like integers.
in python there is no division
between built-in primitive types
like integers and floats and all the other types.
all types are treated the same and
therefore must have the same rules,
but it doesn't stop there it gets even weirder.
look at the behavior of a similar example by
taking x to be an empty list and then appending
one thing onto the end of it using plus equals.
we can see that this time x is pointing to the
same place before and after the plus equals.
for lists which could potentially take
up a lot of memory this makes sense.
if i had a long list i wouldn't want
to copy the whole list over into some
new memory location with one
more element of space on the end.
for list it seems like the id is always preserved,
but as we've seen with integers
that doesn't have to be the case.
that can get you into a lot of trouble if
you're not familiar with how python works.
consider this example.
here i'm using a bad list which
is a class that i wrote myself.
i'm not going to show you the details just yet.
bad list inherits from list and all it
does is change the add and iadd methods.
what this code tries to do is create an empty
list, print out the list, append something
using plus equals, and then append something by
passing it to a function which calls plus equals.
note here that both times i will be calling
the bad list's implementation of plus equals.
the only difference in this case is that this
plus equals is called inside of another function.
we have the following very surprising results.
of course the list is empty before the append, but
after the append only the one two three is there.
what happened to the four five six?
we can see that the iadd method was indeed
called twice and yet only one of them succeeded.
so what's going on?
well looking at the implementation
of iadd it's just delegating to add,
which is calling the add method
of the parent list class,
so in this case it's actually making a new
list with the contents concatenated together.
that explains why this plus equals
succeeded but this one failed.
here bad gets reassigned
to the newly created list,
here l (ell) gets reassigned to the newly created
list, but l (ell) was just a local variable.
it's exactly the same thing that would happen
if i was doing this with just integers.
imagine that bad was the integer zero
and here i was doing plus equals.
plus equals 1 would succeed here because it's
in the same scope and i'm reassigning bad, but
a plus equals 1 here is just reassigning a local
variable, that wouldn't change the outer scope.
this is extra tricky because, aside from reading
the source code of every class that you use,
you have no way of knowing whether plus
equals will act this way or this way.
in fact the python documentation says that
it's perfectly fine to act this way sometimes
and act this way other times.
thankfully all of the classes that i know of
pick one or the other not both,
but theoretically it is possible.
so if you are writing a class and you
want it to work with plus and plus equals,
make sure you do so very very carefully.
i should also mention that the same applies for
any of the other augmented assignment operations
so: plus equals, times equals, or equals,
and equals, ... those kind of things.
that's all i have on this topic.
i really encourage you to download
the code and play with these examples yourself.
it can be really confusing at first but
once you understand what it's actually
doing then it simplifies dramatically.
and don't worry, this actually rarely comes up in
real code so it's not as big a deal
as this video might make it seem.
thanks for watching, if you liked
the video please consider subscribing
and as always slap that like
button an odd number of times.